- Welcome back, everybody!
We've got Brie Larson with us!
(crowd cheers)
Her new movie is called The
Marvels, it's in theaters now
and nowadays, nothing says pop culture
more than Marvel movies.
So, it's time for a pop song trivia game.
This is Pop Pop Quiz.
(exciting jingle plays)
Your jingles are so great.
Okay, Lord, can you help us out?
(choir sings)
He just shows up when I call.
- [Lord] Well, you don't
need my help, Kelly
you got Captain Marvel over
there, so you're in trouble.
You're in trouble, girl.
Lemme tell you.
- Got the OG right here, I like it.
- [Lord] That's right. That's
what I'm talking about.
So, here is how the game works.
I'm gonna read a trivia question,
and the answer to that question
is hidden in the lyrics of a popular song.
So, if I asked "What was
pulling the open slay
as the bells jingled all the way?"
You might answer "One horse."
Got it?
- No
- Oh my gosh.
- Not at all.
- [Lord] Perfect, perfect.
Okay, it's Brie Larson
versus Kelly Clarkson
playing for all the Infinity Stones
as well as a prize for
their side of the audience.
(crowd cheers)
- I don't feel confident.
- That was a lot of thinking.
- [Lord] No pressure.
- [Lord] No pressure at
all. No pressure at all.
- I don't feel confident
in either one of our
skills at this.
- I think I'm really bad and
like this is not a good choice.
- [Lord] Okay, here we go. Are you ready?
- Nope.
- No.
- [Lord] Oh, doesn't matter
because we're going anyway.
Question number one.
According to a very young Michael Jackson,
how easy was A-B-C?
- As one, two, three.
- [Brie] Are you-?
(bell dings)
- [Lord] That's right!
- My buttons broken!
My button is broken!
- That's what I say!
- Do you have like, instant replay?
Because I feel like -
- Like that commercial, the red flags.
- Yes.
- It's amazing.
- [Lord] Wow, you two really are alike.
It is true, it is true.
- Get your hands back away
from that button, Kelly.
- They will stay right here.
Right here, where yours are.
- [Lord] Come on, now, Brie. Come on now.
Focus, here we go.
- I am!
- [Lord] Get it together.
Kelly, you got one point.
- Bring it on, Brie!
- I'm trying!
- [Lord] Use your - well,
pray on it. Pray on it, girl.
Here's question number two.
What time was Gladys Knight's
train leaving for Georgia?
- Are you kidding me?
- Midnight!
(bell dings)
- [Lord] It was midnight.
- Gladys Knight, that's the
most popular song that I know.
- So, you don't have to
finish hearing the question
to buzz in?
- You know, we should explain the rules.
- [Lord] That is correct.
- I like to explain them, after I've won.
- That's a very convenient
time to tell me that.
- [Lord] That's right she took the train-
now, you can take a train to Georgia,
but you can't take a hotdog,
because a hotdog is not a sandwich.
- God, don't get into this, okay?
- [Lord] Think about it.
- He did agree with you.
- [Lord] Okay, here is the next question.
I just blew your mind.
When did En Vogue say that
you'd be receiving their loving?
- [Lord] Brie?
- Tuesday.
(buzzer buzzes)
- [Lord] I'm sorry, that is incorrect.
It was cute, though.
It was cute, I appreciate it.
- Is it "never gonna get it?"
- [Lord] It's never, it's never.
(bell dings)
- Never. Never! Never!
- [Lord] It was never.
(Kelly singing)
- That was a trick question.
- I didn't even understand the question,
I'm gonna be honest with you.
- [Lord] Brie, I'm gonna
give you a point just because
I loved your answer.
- Cool.
- Thank you very much,
thank you! (bell dings)
- [Lord] Okay you get one point.
- Specifically, Tuesday.
- [Lord] Ain't never gonna
get it, ain't never -
Okay, so Kelly, you got three points.
Brie, you got one, come on Captain Marvel.
- Thank you for the reminder.
- [Lord] Let's pull it together.
- Yes, recap!
- [Lord] Come on, now.
Here's your next one.
It would have been nice for George Micheal
at the beginning of Faith
if he could do what?
- Touch your body.
- [Lord] Touch your body!
(bell dings)
(crowd cheers)
- That's a great song.
- [Lord] And it's nice!
It's nice that he asked.
I know not everybody got a body like you.
- That's respectful.
Don't ask En Vogue, though.
- He was respectful before
we progressed there.
- [Lord] Exactly.
- Way to go, George.
- [Lord] But don't be
asking En Vogue, though.
They'll say "never"
- It wouldn't be nice for them.
- [Lord] Here's your next one.
(air horn blows)
- [Lord] That sound right there
means it's time for our last question.
- Last question.
- [Lord] And this one is worth
all the Infinity Stones, okay?
This is worth 40,000 points, why not?
- I am gonna Thanos
the (beep) out of this.
- Wow, 40,000 points?
- [Lord] That's right, that's right.
- Keep your hands back!
- Oh, shoot!
- [Lord] What very French question
was asked in Lady Marmalade?
- Voulez-vous coucher avec moi.
(bell dings)
- [Lord] That's it.
(crowd cheers)
(air horn blows)
- [Lord] And Brie Larson
is the superhero today.
You've done it.
Congratulations, girl you're my favorite.
- Of course, this is my
show, so you're all winners
at the Kelly Clarkson show.
With the holidays right around the corner,
we have the perfect gift for the season.
Roborock's S7 Max Ultra Robot Vacuum
gives you a hands-free cleaning experience
(crowd cheers)
automatically vacuuming
and mopping all in one,
it's also self-washing, -drying - wow! -
- emptying, -refilling.
And you can control it
from your smartphone.
That's incredible!
It's like having your very own housekeeper
at home for the holidays.
And you're all going home with a Roborock.
(crowd continues cheering)
Thank you for kicking my behind.
Lessons in Chemistry is on Apple TV+
trust me, you do not want to miss it.
And also, The Marvels is
in theaters right now,
go check it out.